Abdi.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Yesterday we had begun a very
interesting point and that is the
difference between a pillar and an
obligation in the terminology in the
language of the fukah. And we mentioned
something very curious.
That thing is that when it comes to
wudoo specifically,
the scholars do not mention
them as pillars.
They mention them as obligations.
Thank you.
They mention them as obligations, not as
pillars. So they say conditions and
obligations
not conditions and pillars.
This is interesting. This is unique. Why
is this?
We mentioned yesterday that
a pillar
is something that cannot be
skipped. No matter what, a person cannot
perform an act of worship and leave out
one of its pillars. Whether that is
forgetfully,
purposefully,
whether that is because the person is
unable, the person must fulfill the
pillar.
So for instance,
fasting, fasting has two pillars.
One of the pillars is that a person
have the intention. Second pillar is
that a person refrain from anything that
breaks his his his fast. So why not
name these things pillars meaning the
hands, the arms, the face, the different
places that a person washes during mud?
The answer is and this shows us really
the precision of the scholars that when
they place a particular terminology or a
particular condition,
it comes from a place of immense
knowledge
and that is that not everyone is
obligated to make every part of wudul
based on the person's condition.
For instance, let's say a person is
missing an arm.
Well, one of the pillars of wudul is
that a person wash both of his arms to
the elbow. Well, what if a person is
missing one of his arms? He can't do
that. Then he doesn't do it. Therefore,
it's not really a pillar then, is it? It
is a an obligation.
Let's say a person has some kind of cut
or some kind of injury. And they have a
cast on. Do they wash it? No, they do
not. They skip it purposely.
So this is not a pillar. This is a this
is an an obligation. This is why the
scholars frame it in this way. Contrary
to something for instance, rur is a
pillar of salah. Well, what if a person
can't make rur? They still go through
the motion of rur as best as they can
given their circumstance. Even if they
are on their back and they can only move
their finger, they make with their
finger.
Even if they can't even move their
finger, they make with their eyes.
Right? So it is not something that is
skipped purposely. It is something that
is always done no matter what. However,
when it comes to wool, there are things
which are entirely skipped based on a
person's what? Circumstances. Do we
understand that? This is why they
categorize it as conditions
and obligations. They don't categorize
it as conditions and pillars because if
they can if they categorized it as
pillars this will take us into other
territories.
And this is very important because the
way that we categorize something
this is going to tell us how we treat
that thing.
So for instance I'll give you an example
the
in the hafi medab
they categorize or in the hafiab the
very
well-known opinion
is that they will categorize
as a condition not as a pillar.
The first of categorize it as a as a
condition.
Well, this is very curious. But what
ramifications
ensue
as a result of this categorization?
Well, they say look being that it is a
condition
and a person can make more than one
salah on one condition.
If a person were to be making me
let's say a person were to be making
the
two for some reason and they stood up
for a third forgetfully
continue add two more to it and they're
counted as two and two. Why? Because
just you can make more than one
salah on the same wudoo and wudoo is a
condition of salah. You can make more
than one salah on what? On.
The point here is to articulate how it
critical it is when we categorize things
because categorization
changes the entire way that that thing
is treated. Anytime we ask and we
mentioned this yesterday, if we were to
go and ask the greatest MUI on the
earth, the greatest scholar on the
earth, a fetwa, they are going to reach
back
to the categorization that they first
arrived at and that they've settled on
in order to produce that that fetwa.
And so this is why categorization is so
important. The author here he mentions
three conditions for woo and we
mentioned that this is less popular and
that is that he mentions a nia intention
which is correct. Then he mentions a
tesmah which is contested. However, a
person should always say because some
scholars have obligated it due to the
narration. And then he mentions
which really is one of the of and not
one of the conditions. It's one of the
meaning one of the obligations of so we
will mention that at the end.
For
[Silence]
deep
mah.
So if we were to really quantify how
many obligations for wudoo, we say six.
What are the six obligations of wudoo?
Number one, washing the face
to include the mouth and nose because
the Quran says what?
So every single time we see the prophets
will do mention saiam
it includes the mouth and nose
every time.
Why?
Because he understood that the mouth and
nose are part of the face.
Right? So it is incorrect to say that
it's not mentioned in the Quran. It is
mentioned in the Quran when Allah tells
us to wash our faces and our mouth and
nose is where our face. Okay, so that's
one. Number two, to wash the hands and
arms to include the elbows.
Three,
to wipe over the head and that includes
the ears. The same thing is said for the
ears that is said for the mouth and nose
with respect to the face. The ears are
on your face or on your head. They're on
a person's head. And so when Allah says
wipe over your heads, it is to include
the ears. This is why we never find an
narration where he made wudoo and
skipped the the ears. As a matter of
fact, we will hear that he says
that the two ears are part of the head.
The fourth
obligation of udu is washing the feet
from the toes all the way to include the
ankles.
Number five is alah successively be
done. That this woo be made
successively.
Successively meaning altogether.
And number six that this woo be made in
exactly this order.
that this wool be made exactly in this
order. Meaning it be made face then arms
then head then feet
successively together in this order.
These are what the six pillars or
obligations of woodoo
obligations. These are the six
obligations of wudoo.
So woo has
as mentioned here by the author two
conditions and that is intention and a
tesm right bismillah
which is contested but we should always
do it because
there is an irration mentioning it and
so we can say
and that is saying once a person hears
when a person remembers if a person
forgets the woo is correct and then six
obligations.
The face to include the mouth and nose,
the hands and arms to include the
elbows, the head to include the ears,
the feet to include the ankles, that
they that this all be made successively,
and that this all be made in order.
These are the obligations of
[Silence]
How are you? I'm good. How are you?